es war eine bürgerversammlung in
lohfelden die das leben von walter lübke
schicksalshaft verändern sollte der
politiker wollte erklären warum einem
ort flüchtlinge aufgenommen hatte und
wurde durch zwischenrufe massiv gestört
daraufhin sagte er diese worte
heute weiß man dass stefan ernst und
markus hein den hinteren reihen saßen
diese rufe kamen von ernst markus hardt
und stefan ernst regte sich auf auch
andere rechts gesinnte hatten sich
gezielt unter das publikum gemischt um
walter lücke zu provozieren
seinen freund habe noch nie so bedrückt
wie nach dieser bürgerversammlung erlebt
erinnert sich michael brandt der weiter
lübke 20 jahre kannte er hat mir gesagt
alle im saal 700 leute waren im saal
haben gewusst wen ich gemeint habe
nämlich diese wenigen randalierer die
rechtsradikalen die ständig gestört
haben die den staat verächtlich gemacht
haben und er hätte sich gewünscht dass
eine aufgestanden war und die ihm
unterstützung gegeben hätte dass die
worte walter lüpkes nur an die rechten
störer gerichtet waren bekamen die
wenigsten mit denn markus h stellte kurz
nach der bürgerversammlung ein handy
video ins netz weil da als professor
moriarty unterwegs in dem die störer
vorher fehlten
die manipulation hatte erfolg walter
lübcke wurde das opfer einer
beispiellosen rechten hetzkampagne bekam
auch zahlreiche morddrohungen
vier jahre nach der bürgerversammlung
kommentierte erika steinbach im februar
2009 10 das lohfelden video und
bescherte damit wollte lübke vier monate
vor seiner ermordung noch einmal
haufenweise beschimpfungen und
morddrohungen die asd hetzte kräftig mit
auch nach walter liebestod kfd hat in
den vergangenen jahren an vielerlei
stellen immer wieder dafür sorgt dass
der diskurs sicher nach rechts
verschoben hat dass die hemmschwellen
gesunken sind dass sich andere menschen
sehr bestätigt gefühlt haben in ihren
vorurteilen und was den vorteilen sind
viele taten in diesem land geworden
das ist mehr als nur eine moralische
frage die afg bestreitet die vorwürfe
schriftlich heißt es wer versucht die
afg mit politisch motivierten
gewalttaten in verbindung zu bringen
indem er ihr eine politische
mitverantwortung an diesen andichtet der
diffamiert und das allein aus
politischer motivation
fest steht stefan ernst hatte vor
gericht ausgesagt dass markus h stolz
über den zuspruch im netz gewesen sei
und er sie beide bestärkt hätte und fest
steht auch beide sahen in den letzten
jahren ihre politische heimat bei der
ard so war sie zum beispiel in chemnitz
die fdp hatte zu einem schweigemarsch
aufgerufen weil der deutsche daniel haar
von einem asylbewerber getötet worden
war
auch auf der alf de demo in eisenach
waren stefan ernst und markus haag
gemeinsam stefan ernst ist ein
vorbestrafter neonazi verbüßt in den
90er jahren eine sechsjährige
jugendstrafe
weil er einen sprengstoffanschlag auf
eine asylunterkunft verübt und einen
imam mit einem messer angegriffen hatte
wie auch markus h war ernst lange in der
nordhessischen neonazi szene aktiv hatte
kontakt zu mitgliedern des mittlerweile
verbotenen netzwerks combating dem
bewaffneten arm der rechtsradikalen
organisation blood and honour
vor gericht hatte stefan ernst gesagt
dass er im gefängnis an einem
aussteigerprogramm teilnehmen will
aber gibt es für jemanden wie ihn
überhaupt noch eine chance
das sind sehr sehr langwierige prozesse
wir haben seit jahren verschiedene
aussteigerprogramme beispielsweise und
daher wissen wir dass es nicht nur darum
geht sich von der rechten szene zu
distanzieren sondern ein distanzierung
zu dem gedankengut zu finden das ist ein
jahrelanger prozess mit offenem ausgang
der prozess in frankfurt ist nun zu ende
stefan ernst wurde zur höchststrafe
verurteilt lebenslange haft mit
feststellung der besonderen schwere der
schuld und dem vorbehalt der
sicherungsverwahrung
markus h muss sich lediglich wegen eines
waffendelikts beantworten und kommt mit
einer bewährungsstrafe davon
weil so der richter die beweislage nicht
ausgereicht habe um ihn der beihilfe
oder der mittäterschaft zu verurteilen
dass beide markus h und stefan ernst ein
rassistisches ausländerfeindliches welt
beten
daran besteht kein zweifel juristisch
ist der fall entschieden nun folgt die
politische aufarbeitung in einem
untersuchungsausschuss in wiesbaden
eine frage wird zum beispiel sein warum
der hessische verfassungsschutz stefan
ernst den er noch 2009 in einem internen
vermerk als brandgefährlich bezeichnete
genau auf diesem jahr nicht mehr
beobachtet hat und bei markus h ist
fraglich warum der verfassungsschutz
erkenntnisse über einen bekennen neonazi
nicht weitergeleitet hat mit der folge
dass sich markus eine waffenbesitzkarte
vor gericht erstreiten konnte ein
folgenreicher fehler weil der
verfassungsschutz dafür gesorgt hat dass
sich marcus h legal bewaffnen konnte
dass er gemeinsam legal mit stefan ernst
mutmaßlich schießübung durchführen
konnte sie haben auch illegale
schießübungen durchgeführt und das ist
die verantwortlichkeit des
verfassungsschutzes denn sie hatten
erkenntnisse die verhindert hätten dass
markus h so eine waffenbesitzkarte
bekommt walter lübke war ein
lebensfroher mensch und wurde ermordet
weil er sich für flüchtlinge stark
machte und immer für seine werte
einstand
sein mörder ist nun verurteilt aber
viele fragen bleiben offen